okay today I'm going to talk to you
about ionic bonding ionic bonding occurs
between a metal and a nonmetal on the
periodic table we can see that there's
this kind of jagged line going down like
this everything on the left side of the
periodic table is a metal everything
right of that line is a nonmetal so
ionic bonding is between a metal and the
nonmetal we can have a look at
particular example using sodium and
fluorine metal and nonmetal so from a
grillak table I can see that sodium has
this hit which means sodium has 11
electrons so I'm going to draw these on
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and 11 so so you
because it's in Group one it has one
electron in its outer shell right there
now
the nonmetal I'm going to use is going
to be fluorine just as an example so
from my periodic table I can see
fluorine has got nine electrons in total
which means it will have seven in its
outer shell so if it should be dots one
two three kids so there's nine elections
in total seven in the outer shell
because it's in groups seven meaning
seven electrons in its outer shell so
what I'm going to do is quickly figure
out how many protons electrons and
neutrons each of these have currently
because we'll see why these form ions in
a minute so I could see that this one
has 11 protons because of the proton
numbers 11 therefore it also has 11
electrons to fly my number of neutrons
that just need to do my mass number take
away my atomic number which gives me
this
and for my fluorine I have nine protons
therefore I must have nine electrons to
find my number of neutrons I just do
the mass number take away the atomic
number which gives me this here okay so
what I'm going to do now is I'm going to
think what does each of these atoms need
to do to become more stable so elastin
is most stable when it has a full outer
shell at the moment we can see sodium is
not going to be stable because it has
one electron without a shell
it needs eight electrons in its outer
shell to be stable so sodium is
desperately looking to lose this
particular electron now fluorine however
has seven electrons in our shell it's in
group seven now it just needs one more
electron to have a full outer shell and
be stable so therefore these to form an
ionic bond and this is how it works this
electron from the Alpha shell transfers
over to the fluorine this one now will
have a full outer shell sodium will now
have a full outer shell and be stable
and fluorine will also have a full outer
shell be stable so how does this make
them form ions so this sodium atom
before it had eleven electrons now it's
lost one so now it has 11 protons and
ten electrons this fluorine however has
gained one electrode remember the
protons and the neutrons are in the
nucleus the atoms and do not move
anywhere it's only electrons that
transfer over
sohba credits gained an electron it now
has nine protons and ten electrons so
what does that mean in terms of charge
now remember protons are positive and
electrons are negative so what this
means is this atom has ten eleven
positive and ten negative which means we
have one more positive than negative
this means that sodium
is going to be have a charge of +1 when
it's just +1 we just wrote + rather than
putting the number 1 next to it because
it's got one more proton than it has
electrons now a fluorine however this
forms a different eye on because we've
gained one electron we now have 9
positive electrons but 3 positive
protons and 10 negative electrons which
means overall we've got one more
negative than positive so we've got a
minus charge so these are ions an ion is
a charged particle which has an uneven
number of protons and electrons because
either gained electrons or it's lost
electrons the last thing we need to know
is why do these two things then bond
together and the answer is right here
because we have a positive ion and a
negative ion there's an electrostatic
attraction between the two because
remember in science opposites attract so
that is the essentials of ionic bonding
between a metal and a nonmetal we've got
to think about is it trying to gain or
lose electrons and how many and based on
how many electrons it's lost and what
positive charges are going to have faced
for how many electrons it's gained what
negative charges are going to have and
the reason why they've gone together is
because and then attract together rather
is because positive and negative attract
thank you